des ballons de plusieurs mètres de
diamètre flottent au dessus des
centaines de partisans rassemblés sur
l'esplanade du palais des congrès pour
son dernier meeting le président
congolais souhaite frapper les esprits
des électeurs avec un objectif être
réélu dès le premier tour comme en 2016
alors que le pib du pays pourrait
reculer de 9% cette année
denis sassou n'guesso promet des mesures
sociales et une politique tournée vers
la jeunesse face au président congolais
six rivaux dont l'un de ses anciens
ministres mathias dzon lors de son
dernier meeting
il s'est dit lui aussi prêt à redonner
espoir à la jeunesse du pays
il ya cinq ans la réélection de denis
sassou n'guesso avait entraîné le
déclenchement d'un conflit à huis clos
dans la région du pool entre l'armée les
forces locales menées par le pasteur to
me cette année l'ancien chef rebelle
lançant un appel au calme
le conseil national des républicains
convaincus que la démocratie doit suivre
son cours normal pense que l'élection
présidentielle doit se faire dans la
paix même si le climat politique sans
plus apaisée cette année les conditions
d'organisation de la présidentielle
congolaise suscite des craintes
la conférence épiscopale a déjà émis de
sérieuses réserves sur la transparence
du scrutin
dans ce contexte le secrétaire général
de l'onu appelle toutes les parties à
oeuvrer en faveur d'un processus
électoral apaisé depuis sa prise de
pouvoir en 1979 denis sassou n'guesso
n'a été battu qu'une seule fois c'était
en 1992
redevenu président par les armes en 1990
est redevenu président par les armes en
1997 il compte bien le demeurer
en 2015 il a fait modifier la
constitution qui limitait à deux le
nombre de mandats présidentiels